for two one point game both teams with
multiple timeouts and neither team fouls
to give both in the penalty under two to
play harden step back
what's up the three got head chats good
James Harden double team that a chance
for a four-point play look at the crowd
and said wow I think he is it all of
himself at this point don't reach the
skis gonna preach and then you're forced
to close out and one you should have
just said I am a bad man and I got this
game on lock Beverly with his sixth foul
vows out and harden with a chance to put
them up now by five
[Applause]
this is the free-throw
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Lou Williams finds Paul George George a
three-pointer rattles in and out that
one halfway down Rockets who had their
eight game winning streak snapped in
Denver on Wednesday trying to get a big
Road win here capela
short gets its rebound double-team layup
banks it home six-point lead 19 rebounds
for capela Lou Williams for three that's
good
both coaches are furious Mike D'Antoni
is hi Eric Lewis telling the players on
the Rockets bench to get back on them on
the sidelines at James Harden was
visibly demonstrative with his team
telling him to get off the floor
[Applause]
Westbrook
drives inside lost that got it back that
was close to a double dribble unless it
was knocked out of his hands pass inside
Tucker
it's good PJ Tucker another big play and
the Clippers call timeout exacts
arm and that's why Russell lost control
of all these two teams getting after it
Paul George corner three that's good
much shot from George and it's back to
tow still plenty of time remaining
though eyeliners on Harden fine
Westbrook Westbrook acid side the
cappella gathers block to Michael Green
knocked it away Leonard on the spin move
had it lost that got it back again
Williams for Trey's Clippers take the
lead timeout Rockets been consistently
traffic trying to get it out of his
hands here there we go Leonard
unhardened harden on the drive hits
inside got bumped Leonard doesn't like
the call but harden will shoot two a
chance to take the lead at the
free-throw line
[Applause]
the James goes quickly gets the step
[Applause]
Doc Rivers can challenge this season
will say about James being the guy is
the hook the defenders are
so just just watch the off arm and it's
the second time it's been Leonard that's
that's guard to them rather grabs
Leonard's arm just as the last time who
I complain absolutely
Doc Rivers did not challenge it as
Martin hits the free-throw
PJ Tucker playing with five fouls
guarding Co a Leonard Leonard on the
drive pull-up jumper
Clippers by one fifteen point two
remaining rockets do have a timeout
decide not to call it into the hands of
James Harden Westbrook for three
won't go rebound George tips away and
then they finally follow with 1.2
remaining
still not over yet even if he hits the
free throws because the Rockets do have
a time left
they run pick-and-roll with Lou Williams
and Kauai looked at PJ battle but as he
is reacting collides just waiting for
his window to take the shot that takes
patience and composure and he had both
24 points for Leonard
Russell Westbrook thousand and Paul
George will go to the free-throw line
where he's 6 of 7
[Music]
[Applause]
now a chance to make it a three-point
game Sefolosha comes in with Westbrook
fouling out again Mike D'Antoni he
didn't use that timeout Boise glad
because now he he has a chance to
advance the ball on the front porch so
important all five defenders a challenge
without fouling out here
[Applause]
clemont's comes across bharden hasn't
knocked out of his hands Clemens has it
that's it the Clippers